- Good morning.
Welcome, everyone, to
day two of our workshop.
Yesterday was absolutely fantastic
and not only did I learn a lot,
but I think we managed to
break many language barriers
as it were in trying to
understand the concepts
and models that people
across disciplines use
when thinking about the kinds of inference
and the sort of pitfalls in
many of the methodologies
that we are using, the
limitations across fields.
So it is my great pleasure
today to introduce
our Dean of Faculty of the
Faculty of Arts and Sciences,
Professor Tamar Gendler,
who is an exemplar of
interdisciplinary scholarship
and whose support, I mean in her own work
she has worked across
multiple feats, philosophy,
psychology, cognitive
neuroscience, and is very committed
as, you know, an administrator
in the university,
she has been really heralding
sort of intellectual crossing
of boundaries and many initiatives
and programs to really
facilitate conversations.
As you all know, universities,
though we are all in
with various expertise
that often speaks to very
similar sets of problems
and challenges that we work on,
we don't get to talk as much.
So with the support of the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities
that Yale has very enthusiastically,
not just supported,
but encouraged faculty to
attend and be involved,
Tamar has, as I said, in her
own scholarship and beyond,
really been a steward for
cross-disciplinary work.
So it is my absolute delight
to invite her to say a few words.
Tamar, thank you so much for coming.
- [Tamar] Thank you so much, Priya.
(attendees clapping)
Thank you, all, and
I'm sorry I wasn't here
to greet you yesterday morning.
These are, as you know,
challenging times for universities.
I was in New York helping
some of our colleagues
and supporters understand
how hard we're trying.
But though these are trying
times for universities,
this conference is an example
of what makes universities truly distinct
and what it is about the
imaginative enterprise
of creating an institutional structure
that is simultaneously
engaged in the preservation,
the creation, and the
transmission of knowledge.
And in my mind, this conference epitomizes
what is great about universities.
It is asking a deep and
intellectual question
that is simultaneously of theoretical
and practical significance.
It is distinct, I think,
to be able to have
a series of events that
simultaneously engage
some of the deepest and most
abstract philosophical work,
really about the nature of understanding
in its most fundamental sense,
and that simultaneously brings in,
in very real practical ways
a set of empirical disciplines.
It's rare to find a topic
that is not at the periphery
of one field and the center of another,
but at the center of every
field of which it is a part.
And it is rare to find a subject
that though centrally part of each field
and common enough to
merit joint discussion
is differentially illuminated
by different methodologies.
So that's some theoretical
reasons to think
this series of events is doing
what a university can do.
But I also wanna point out,
because I have a second hat,
I'm not just responsible
for intellectual matters,
though I take great joy in
reading the academic work
of my colleagues regularly.
The second thing I wanna emphasize
is that this series of events
of which all of you are a part
took advantage of structural
features of the university,
of structural features of the ecosystem
of which we are all apart,
and to the extent that the
group I am addressing is a set
of stewards of the intellect
at their own universities.
I wanna point out to you
some of the practical
features of this event.
This project was carried out over years.
It used multiple modalities.
It took advantage of the fact
that people can drop in and out
and nonetheless be part of a
loosely knit social network.
For each of the events
that it carried out,
it had it both in real time
and available for subsequent observation.
It brought unexpected groups of people
into interaction with one another.
It took advantage of
the funding environment
in which we find ourselves.
The Templeton Foundation
is deeply interested
in interdisciplinary issues
in fundamental questions.
It supplemented those resources
with an entity on campus,
the Franke, that had already
established a mailing list
and a brand that allowed
these events to be legible.
And it involved a wide range
of faculty on and off campus.
Priya did the very smart thing
of very early alerting this to me.
And so when I went around
and met with supporters of the university,
this was one of the things I talked about.
Every single thing that
Priya did with regard
to this event is something
that every single one of you
can do at your home institution.
Think about what are the networks
that have already given
us a pre-established list
of individuals with interest
in a large range of questions?
Who are the nodes at your university
that if you tell them about this,
they will tell the world about this?
This is not only in your
self-interest as scholars.
The university in the world
is an entity that is at risk.
It is being challenged for
reasons, some appropriate,
some inappropriate.
But the more we focus and
celebrate core mission,
the more likely it is the
universities will remain
the entities that they have long been.
So that's where I was yesterday.
I was in defend the university space
and I was writing this on the train
and so I wrote you a little
defend the university.
But I also wanna do a couple
of specific reflections
on the topic that this group
has been thinking about.
And then I'm gonna just
close by reading a poem
because this doesn't have anybody
from the English
department and so I thought
I'd give you a little bit
of literature at the end.
So on the front page of the webpage,
which I assume is the
cover page of the proposal
that you sent to Templeton,
it certainly feels like the
cover page of a proposal
that one would send to Templeton,
is the incredibly resonant
quote from Hume that,
"No amount of observation of white swans
can allow the inference
that all swans are white,
but the observation of a single black swan
is sufficient to refute that conclusion."
And I don't get to do a lot of philosophy,
I don't get to do a lot
of reflecting on texts
so it was a total pleasure
just to live in this
quotation and its depth.
And I just wanna give
voice to three thoughts
that occurred to me.
One, I had not realized till I started
thinking about this quote,
that one way to describe
what almost every academic
does is to figure out
which features of the
world that seem shallow
are actually deep and
which features of the world
that seem deep are actually shallow.
That is, for example, the project
of our Department of Women's,
Gender, and Sexuality Studies
which aspects of the
world that seem universal
may be particular, which
aspects of the world
that seem particular may
actually have deep foundations
as I suspect we will
hear in our next talk.
But over and over and over
again, including in the work
that we do in engineering, which ways
in which this substance feels brittle
have to do with deep
features of its structure,
which are merely manifestations
of the idiosyncratic way
in which we find it?
So that's just thought one.
Hume tells us a way to think
about the questions that we ask
is to think about where we are
mistaking surface for depth,
where we are mistaking depth for surface.
Ultimately, a platonic
question about our capacity
to understand the nature of reality.
Two, if Hume had lived in Australia,
it wouldn't have occurred to
him that all swans were white.
In Australia, lots of swans are black.
It is contingent what it is
that we take to be ordinary
and what it is that we take to be unusual.
That reminder is crucial for
all of our investigation.
That is not a political statement,
it's an epistemic fact about the world
that all of us are only partially
exposed to elements of it
and on that basis we draw conclusions.
Note that as we build artificial analogs
to our own intelligence, they
too don't live in Australia.
That is to say they
too are getting exposed
only to that which is
electronically represented.
And just like Hume, who
was very, very smart,
they might fail to
recognize how idiosyncratic
the part of the world to which
they have been exposed is.
Third point.
How do we gather
information about the world?
One of the questions that this
assembly is thinking about
is the entire set of
methodological worries that arise.
To what extent do we seek information?
To what extent does seeking information
distort the information
that we're able to get?
How do we become active perceivers?
I spend a lot of time, I
oversee all of the tenure
and promotion cases that come before us,
I see the methodologies
that ethnography brings us,
which says, sit back, don't theorize
and you will see things more truly.
I see the methodology that's
brought by areas of inquiry
that say if you do not have
a theoretical framework,
you will mistake what is
important for what is unimportant.
Both those things are true
and the methodological
diversity of this event
seems to me to capture
that in profound ways.
All right, those are
three thoughts on Hume.
Let me close with a wonderful
poem by Mary Oliver.
This is not a hard,
deep poem to understand.
This is just a beautiful
celebration of our experience
as humans on earth.
"The Swan."
"Did you see it too, drifting
all night on the black river?
Did you see it in the morning,
rising into the silvery air,
an arm full of white blossoms,
a perfect commotion of silk
and linen as it leaned into
the bondage of its wings?
A snow bank, a bank of
lilies, biting the air
with its black beak.
Did you hear it fluting and whistling,
a shrill dark music, like
the rain pelting the trees,
like a waterfall knifing
down the black ledges?
And did you see it finally
just under the clouds,
a white cross streaming across the sky,
its feet like black leaves,
its wings like the stretching
light of the river?
And did you feel it in your heart
how it pertained to everything?
And have you finally figured
out what beauty is for
and have you changed your life?"
Thank you so much for inviting
me in for your assembly.
(attendees clapping)
- Thanks, Tamar for that
very, very lovely welcome
and thanks to all the
attendees who are here.
So we are opening this morning's session
with the first talk.
Eduardo, take it away.
- Thank you.
Can you hear me there?
Yes.
Well, good morning everyone.
I wanna stay on time.
Thank you, Priya, for inviting me.
I'll have a few words to
really share with you all.
Why is it that I'm here?
Thanks, Tamar, I'll
have some comments about
what you were referring to before.
You have the title there.
We're gonna move from to
look into some different type
of causation, causation,
the way we examine it
in biological anthropology.
And I will say more
about that in a minute.
What I wanna do first is
get the clicker to work.
There you go.
I think it is important I
put together this slide,
which I don't usually show
to give you some background
on my own background, right?
I'm not a philosopher.
That much you've learned from yesterday.
I'm not a computer scientist,
I'm not a statistician.
I'm a biologist by training
and with focus on behavioral sciences
and that has got me to
move across disciplines.
And I really think that
maybe it's helped me
to really appreciate and
embrace the opportunity
that this workshop is
bringing to all of us.
My very first research
paper was working in a lab
that studies the neurobiology
of learning and memory.
We were using some short crops
that we were collecting from
the beaches in Buenos Aires,
bringing them to the lab,
giving them electric shocks
to see if they could learn or not.
They don't.
But then I went on to the PhD
to work with some
experimental psychologists,
so I went from neurobiology
to experimental psychology,
tackling some of the same questions
that I will be presenting to you,
but in a controlled setting of a lab
at the California Primate
Center with my mentors there.
So I'm gonna come back to this
because I think it's one of the things
that I would like to share broadly
with my colleagues in
biological anthropology
and I was discussing with
one of you over breakfast,
I think there's a lot to
be said about the benefit
of taking the leap and
cutting across disciplines
as you develop your own trajectory.
The compass for the talk.
Some of you still remember
what a compass is.
Some of you only know about GPS.
So what I wanna do is give you
a little bit of a few minutes
of why I'm talking here today.
Then, I'm gonna make a
few comments on causality
in the biological sciences.
A little bit of an introduction
to how we do that in
biological anthropology
with some very general examples
on questions on the type
of evidence we collect.
And then the core of the
30 minute presentation
will be on some examples
from my own research
on pair bonding, monogamy, and fatherhood.
I really plan to be done in 30 minutes
so that we can have full 15
minutes of questions and answers
because I have enjoyed those so much
as well as our times together
over breakfast, tea and lunch.
Why am I here?
So sometime in, I think it was in 2018,
I had my first teaching relief
for, and I went on leave,
and I used that semester
so that was five years ago,
to really start pondering and reflecting,
I wanna know what I know, right?
Sometimes you feel like I only know
that I don't know anything,
but I wanted to know what I know.
And I spent a lot of
time on that semester,
I put together a course
on scientific thinking and reasoning.
And one of the books that I went back to,
I knew this book, I don't
know how many of you know it,
it's from two British colleagues,
"Stop Working & Start Thinking."
And I think that cartoon says so much
of the challenge we face on a daily basis.
We can seldom find time
to stop, ponder, reflect.
I mean, just the pressures to get money,
we don't even know what
we need the money for,
but we just need to get more money.
And so in 2019, Dean
Gendler launched a program
that was absolutely brilliant,
I thank, it continues to run,
which was the Teaching
Relief for Learning.
We were invited to come up with an idea,
we needed to convince them
that we could make good use
of that time to take courses
instead of teaching courses,
go back to the classroom.
And that was a time when
I was starting to to say,
listen, we're not reflecting
on what we have learned
in a causal inference sense
within my own research.
I mean, I have been doing my
research now for 25 years,
so I knew that some of the
social sciences were developing
all kinds of methodological
tools to get at causality.
And so I literally enrolled
in a research methods course
in causal inference, taught
in political sciences,
and then I took an undergraduate course,
one of our survey
introductory courses in stats.
And I did both and I completed
my homework and I passed.
It was fantastic, it was
fantastic because I realized that,
oh, my, do we need to
bring some of those tools
into biological anthropology?
I continued working this.
There are all kinds of developments
that I'd be happy to share with you
because like Tamar said,
maybe some of these ideas,
you'll bring to your institutions.
But it was only a few months ago
as I was developing a new
course on causal inference
that I just went onto the Yale website
and typed causal inference.
And I will admit here right now,
that I only learned about
the causal inference project
that we have at our institution
maybe three, four months ago.
And yes, the more you
work, the luckier you get.
I emailed Priya and I said,
I wanna know more about this.
And that got us talking
and I jumped on the wagon of
what Priya has been doing.
And so that's why I'm here,
only because I was seeking information,
I was looking for ways
in which I could expand
my intellectual interest
and prepare myself better
for doing my research.
So that's my history of why I'm here.
A little bit of the history,
I mean, biology has a long
history of of thinking
and contributing to the
development of statistics.
I mean, this is just two
graphs from a wonderful book
that most of you probably
know, "The Book of Why"
by Judea Pearl, is Sir Francis Galton
towards the end of the 19th
century, just developing ideas
for explaining the inheritance
of height in humans.
I mean, at the same time,
developing the central limit theorem.
And these were right,
this is a figure one from a paper in PNAS.
My understanding is that
historians of science
consider this the first path diagram.
He was trying to understand
what causes color code
in the Guinea pigs that he was studying.
So late 19th century, early
20th century move forward
and you go to an extremely
influential paper
published by evolutionary
biologist, Ernst Mayr, at Harvard.
In 1961, he published a paper called,
"Causes and Effects in Biology."
And what I wanna draw from
that paper to our two concepts
that I'm gonna come back as I discuss
how we try to do causal inference,
proximate causes and ultimate causes.
Just think of those as
in proximate causes,
we're trying to understand
why things happens
in a mechanistic way, can be the cell,
can be the organ, can be the individual,
you can think of physiology,
you can think of energetics,
you can think of endocrinology.
Ultimate causes, Ernst Mayr
was developing this paper
from what I read, in trying
to bring some balance
to what was a very strong tendency
to focus on genetics from
the twenties and thirties.
Himself being an organismic
evolution biologist
thought that we also
needed to understand causes
at an adaptive level, functional level.
And that's what it's
been referred ever since
as ultimate causes.
Why don't we come back,
as I examine what progress have we made
in understanding proximate
and ultimate causes
for the phenomenon that
are of my interest.
At that time, this is
the top panel of a figure
of the paper that I show next.
You can see that the understanding there
was that causality was
rather unidirectional,
it was bottom up.
You just go from the genome
in a very programmed way
to the cell, the organism,
and the environment.
And whatever that happens
in that generation one,
that's pretty much
inherited to generation two.
And that was set.
And of course this has
changed over the years.
And now, for many, many, for a long time,
we've developed
subdisciplines like evo-devo
where we understand that causality,
we need to understand
causality at different levels.
Yes, there is an influence of
the genome in what comes next,
but so there is influences of what happens
at the level of the cell, of the organism,
and the environment, and
it is not unidirectional,
but it is reciprocal.
And some of these changes
that occurred during ontogeny,
during your lifetime
may be also influencing
the following generation.
So we have moved away, most
of us, I would like to think,
from what all of you are familiar with,
which was so influential as well
and with positive and
negative consequences
as portrayed in the
"The Selfish Gene" book
that Richard Dawkins wrote,
it's almost 50 years ago.
So that is what we call these days,
the extended evolutionary synthesis.
How do we do this within
biological anthropology?
In a nutshell, biological anthropology,
which we also call evolution anthropology,
physical anthropology,
we are trying to understand
what it is, what it means
to be human if we take biology
and evolution into account.
So when you study humans, of
course we have come to realize,
embrace, include the component of culture.
You cannot understand
what it means to be humans
if you to consider culture.
But something that is, it's
a rather challenge these days
to communicate in classroom is
that I am of the firm opinion
that everything begins with biology
because at the end of the
day, we are made of cells,
we are made of genes, et cetera.
But you cannot ignore culture either.
So these are some questions that we ask
both on a very deep timescale
and also a very broad spatial scale.
What makes us different
from other living organisms,
for example, chimps?
When did we really start cooperating
for producing or obtaining the food
as the drawing on the top right shows you?
And once we got that food,
when did we start making fire?
Were we using the fire to warm ourselves?
Were we using the fire to cook?
And now that we cook,
suddenly our complete
nutritional functions change.
When did we start walking on two legs?
These are some typical classical questions
that we ask in human biology,
in biological anthropology.
And then we go on to get data
and we never get all the
data we would like to get.
This is, by the way, I was thinking
there's something I keep
telling students all the time
and I think that you'll
appreciate and agree with this.
We forget that we are
never getting the data
we would like to get, right?
We get what we can, not
what we would like to.
And the students don't understand it.
And I sometimes I feel like we forget that
when we're reading papers
or reviewing grants.
The kind of evidence we can get, fossils.
That is, I would say
that's rather unequivocal,
we can hold a skull, right?
We can hold a stone tool,
but we can quibble about who made it.
Carrying and storing, we can
look at material culture.
Genetics.
There is information on genetics
that can help us reconstruct the past.
Behavior, and that's my focus.
The catchphrase for behavior
is behavior doesn't fossilize.
And one of you showed
yesterday, I apologize,
I think it was Thomas, the first slide
was some footprints on a beach
and then we looked at a track of a fox.
Well, what do we make of that?
What do you make of that
if now you find a footprint
that you know has been dated
to 1.3 million years ago
in the savannas of Africa?
You can make of that a lot.
How have we used these approaches
and what are the kinds of
questions that are closer
to what I've been doing for this time?
One of the things that
so many of us wonder
is in what makes us humans,
what makes us love, right?
Well, what are the proximate
and ultimate causes
that have developed a living organism
that can connect emotionally
with another living organism
in a very peculiar way that we don't see
in many taxa, right?
We refer to that
establishing some pair bonds.
What is it that makes some
living primates develop
these kind of emotional
bond in a very peculiar way
with young, I'm not gonna
call them their offspring
for a while, we'll see,
we'll come back to that,
and some of the living
organisms don't do it?
Paternal care.
More specifically, we're narrowing down
to the false side of my research.
Why are some primates pair-living
and socially monogamous
where some males such excellent fathers?
Those are really the two central questions
that I want to use to share some findings,
but probably even more than
that share some concerns,
some limitations, really embracing
the uncertainty that there
is in all that I've done.
Much of the research that I'm synthesizing
in my early 17 minutes
has done in collaboration
with hundreds of students, assistants,
and some colleagues,
these, I wanted to mention.
Anthony Di Fiore, we were
students together at UC Davis
when we were grad students 10 years ago.
Marcelo Rotundo.
You didn't pick up, you're
not paying attention.
Marcelo Rotundo has been the
field manager in Argentina
working with me for 30 years.
Maggie Corley and Alba
are two junior colleagues
who have joined the
project now for some time.
And again, going back to when I said,
listen, we need to do something.
So it was 18, 19, 2019 that we
started working on this paper
that we published in the "Yearbook
of Physical Anthropology"
summarizing the research we've done
with some of these primates.
In fact, it took us five years,
no, it was published in 2020,
we started working on this on 2013.
There was a science paper
published by one of my colleagues,
one of the most famous
social evolution biologist,
Tim Clutton-Brock at Cambridge,
making some claims about
the evolution of monogamy.
And let's say we did not agree
with many of the conclusions
and we just do not have
it in us to produce
the quick turnaround to
refute some of the claims.
It took us seven years.
It's the kind of work that
it's thorough, it's deep,
it doesn't make it into science,
you cannot summarize it in a tweet.
But we published a 60 page
paper that we're very proud of
because we really got into the
details of the issues we had
with the inferences made
for the evolution of
social monogamy in mammals.
Our labs, our labs, we have
labs in the forests of Ecuador,
Peru, and Argentina, and
we've been working there
for anywhere between a few
years and 28 years in Argentina.
And I work also in labs in the states
where some of my colleagues
are in Bastrop, Texas
and Davis, California are
responsible for captive colonies
of some of these pair-living taxa.
I'm beginning to look
back to my background,
the importance of tackling
the same questions
from different experimental approaches
and the power, the power
of moving back and forth
between what a lab can offer you
and what the natural setting
of the field can offer you
and drawing the best from each.
I will not be talking about this,
but we're gonna have 15
minutes if any of you,
so those of you traveling from
Europe who are still trying
to figure out how to deal with jet lag,
we've done a lot of research
on the evolution of diurnality
and nocturnality because the owl monkeys
that I studied in Argentina
are not nocturnal,
were not working during the night.
I did that when I was young.
Not doing it again, it doesn't
pay off, among other reasons.
But just bring this up
during the questions
if you wanna learn more about that.
Tons of students assistants,
I wanna thank them.
We do that a lot.
Please let your own students reach out.
We always have opportunities
to bring young scholars to the
field to do research with us.
And we have some wonderful facilities.
We have a field station
in the city of Formosa,
we can host researchers,
collaborators, and we have camp.
Now we're going to Argentina,
the lab in Argentina.
And the bottom right image is showing you
roughly 200 hectares, 500 acres,
which is really our main backyard
that you can see in yellow,
the system of trails.
One of you was asking me, what do you do?
Well, we produce the data
that feeds into those documentaries
that hopefully some of you
have watched and enjoy.
BBC, Netflix, "Life on Our
Planet," David Attenborough.
We're producing the data
that goes into that.
That's the kind of setting,
that's the kind of lab where we are.
I wanna go more deep because
I was thinking about it,
when was the last time you took a course
on evolutionary biology
or that you heard about
evolutionary biology methods?
My impressions that for most
of you, it's been a while,
so I felt it would be interesting to hear,
I mean, I was learning from you
what happens day in, day out
so I wanna share a little bit of that.
What happens day in, day out
is that you go out in the
forest, you wake up early,
you drink mate, and you really
have to go find the subjects
from which you are gonna
be collecting data.
And how you do that, it's
a challenge in itself.
More and more we are
relying on some of the chips
and devices that some of
you have been telling us
how you produce.
In this case, what we're doing
is we're capturing owl monkeys
with a rifle with CO2 darts.
Sounds easy.
It's an extremely complicated procedure.
And we are feeding them
with telemetry colors
to track them in the forest.
We're also feeding them
with accelerometers
that your iPad tracker,
we dunno how many steps
they need to take to stay fit,
but we can collect a lot of data
that summarizes their activities.
So we do that and that
allows us to find them.
And when you find them, it
depends on what you're doing,
it depends on the day,
it depends on the samples
you're collecting,
you may be collecting
just direct observations.
It's funny how we've been talking
about observations, right?
I mean, my goodness, could we spend a week
discussing what we mean by that?
Some of us are calling a
footprint an observation of war.
It's only of a footprint
since the fox wasn't there,
nor the human was there, right?
So sometimes we are
literally collecting data
from what the animal is doing.
Sometimes we're collecting
monkey poop from the ground.
Sometimes we're just
going through the forest
collecting what we call life history data,
get a sense of what's happening
in each of those families.
We've been doing that year round.
And this is, I mean, I
need to go tell our dean
that it doesn't stop, we need
to keep doing it year round,
we need to be in the field.
The monkeys don't stop,
the soap opera continues.
And we've been doing that
nonstop since May, 1996.
When we do the math, and it's not big data
by any means of this workshop,
but it comes down to,
imagine that for 28 years,
you've had somebody in the
forest four, five hours a day
every single day of 25 years.
That captures the effort that has come.
In terms of genetics in
terms of of ultimate causes,
I mean, can we start
looking at what happens
over an extended period of time?
We're looking now at the fourth generation
of identifying individuals.
These are not fruit flies,
but they're not chimps.
So there's a lot of power
in studying a system
where you can be looking at
great grandchildren in 20 years,
something you cannot do
with whales or elephants.
We collect genetic data.
And one of the reasons we capture them
is because we can produce
high-quality genetic material
for some of these animals of
known sex, known date of birth,
we have cell lines established
as part of the collection
that I developed for the San Diego Zoo.
Sometimes we collect tissue.
And other times, we just collect feces.
Again, methods.
What does it mean?
We're gonna come back to that.
I mean, what does it mean
when I estimate some mediator
of a potential causal path from
something I measure in poop,
in blood, in an individual cell?
We collect behavioral life
history, demographic data,
and of course we have a
very comprehensive panel
of variables to say something
about the environment.
Why are some primates pair-living
and socially monogamous?
By socially monogamous,
I'm just saying that they
spend time together, right?
Without going into the details
of what may or may not happen
in our modern societies,
people live as a pair in one apartment,
God knows what happens
when they're not there,
but we call them socially monogamous.
We're gonna tackle that first question.
And I wanna go slowly on this one.
So I wanna capture your attention
again, please on purpose
and keeping the text,
we're gonna read slowly
because it's central to understanding
the challenge of the inferences
we're trying to make.
Let me just say, to give you
a little bit of a timescale,
is that these owl monkeys,
if we were to connect them
on a phylogenetic tree to humans,
we'd probably need to go
back 40 million years ago,
if I remember that well.
So we're making, kind of
we're taking a big leap
in the inference.
This is from a paper, it was a note.
Actually, this is one of these editorials
on the article that I
was referring to before
by one of my colleagues,
evolution of mammalian society.
The hypothesis is the narrative
model that we wanna explore
says that the distribution
and abundance of food,
top left panel illustrated
with some fruits,
or maybe the predators, the middle photo,
or maybe the pathogens, the bottom,
yeah, those potential factors,
it's unfortunate that
it says here, determine,
they are associated with whether females
of a given mammalian species
are solitary or gregarious.
Now, we move to the right,
the female may be socially,
solitary or gregarious
in relationship to food,
to predators, to the risk
of transmission disease.
The hypothesis is that
male social strategies
are determined in a second
step by infanticide risk.
How much a female is concerned,
there's a risk that some male
may come and kill her infant.
Options for parental care,
engaging males in the care of a young.
Intrasexual selection.
By that we mean that
it's within the same sex,
males fighting between them
for access to those females.
All of that is gonna determine
the spatial temporal distribution
of receptive females.
So we move to the right panel
and depending on these
conditions, we're expecting,
we're predicting that we're
gonna see a social arrangement
along pairs, one male and one female.
We may see solitary
females with some males
roving over the ranges of them.
Or we may see one male holding
control to several females.
We may see several females
and several males together.
That's the idea.
This drawing in a number of
forms has profoundly influenced
all research done in primatology
and to a large extent, in
biological anthropology.
Of course, we can make it
a little bit more nuanced
and you can also draw this.
And how on earth do you go into our forest
and try to produce data that will give you
a sense of satisfaction,
these days, I worry about that
more than whether it's
gonna get published or not,
that you have really made progress?
And you have no choice,
at least, I don't know of
any of any other option,
but to choose a section of that.
And I just want to
illustrate what we've done
for that top right quarter of the graph,
we said, okay, let's examine,
let's collect some data,
define some variables that
relate to the distribution
of males and females in space
to see how much they move,
how they move, how that may contribute
to understanding the ability
of a male to monopolize access
to a female, right?
The ability of males and females
to mate with other partners.
Really, you're really imagining yourself,
I mean this is what I tell the
students, you need to decide.
I mean, can you have two girlfriends?
Well, maybe if one is in New Haven,
the other one is in Milford.
Can you have two boyfriends?
Well, maybe now with Zoom, if you decide
that you'll maintain those
relationships virtually,
but you cannot have
girlfriend or boyfriend,
10 of them in 10 different
countries all over the world.
And that's a little bit
the exercise we're doing.
So our monkeys, one of the
three texts that we study
everywhere you look at always
you find them pair-living,
what we call socially monogamous
and pair-bonded, meaning that we infer
that there is this preference
and that's thinking about humans,
that happens all over the world.
Humans are developing
a primarily relationship with
one single other individual.
Its change can be the same sex,
different sex, same gender,
but there's always a preference
for one over the others.
Owl monkeys always pair-living,
always pair-bonded.
This is the forest I
was showing you before.
You go into a forest and
you have 18 of these groups
and they're really distributed in space
like I'm showing you there.
Remember, that's roughly
200 hectares, 500 acres.
Let's take two of those, backyards, right?
Think of them as backyards,
they're roughly five hectares,
that's maybe 12 acres.
So these guys are holding
a backyard of five acres.
One male, one female.
There's another group
that has their neighbors,
another five hectares.
The problem is that we also look around
and in these neighborhoods,
some of them got to really
have twice as much area,
but they still have only
one male and one female.
So what we asked ourselves is why is it
that if some of these
males have the ability,
the proximal causes, the
mechanisms to really range
over 10 hectares,
why don't we see some evolution
that produces a male
that now is gonna range
over the ranges of these two
smaller territories in red?
Why don't we get a drive
for the evolution of a polygenous male?
If the guy can cover 10 hectares,
if he can monitor 10 hectares,
why don't just monitor
two territories of five
instead of one of 10?
The answer is we have no clue why not.
So that's really after
28 years, there is no,
I mean, it's very, very
difficult to resolve this.
What we're trying to do now
is get into much more detail
in measuring the
distribution of resources,
which is extremely challenging.
Why?
I mean, some of these males,
actually all of these males
are wonderful fathers.
Why are some males excellent fathers?
And that's a fascinating
question in evolutionary biology.
Let me tell you why.
You can connect with these guys
being wonderful fathers, right?
Male penguin keeps an eye on the chicks.
Mom goes fishing and finding food.
Seahorses, you probably know
that the males hold the pregnancy.
But mamas are very, very different.
For one thing, fertilization
is inside the female tract
and that generates father uncertainty.
And second, mom, as opposed to the penguin
and the seahorse, mom is
stuck with the investment,
with the demand for energetics
during pregnancy and lactation.
So it is a puzzle in
mammalian reproductive biology
why males would commit to a single female
in a socially monogamous relationship.
One possibility, we do know
that owl monkeys provide
an awful lot of care.
I mean, if you have children,
if you have grandchildren,
encourage them to browse the web,
to look at videos of owl monkeys
taking care of the babies is fascinating.
A couple days after the baby's born,
the father is primarily involved
in taking care of the
young, except for nursing,
the male does everything.
And we do feel based on
data from the lab as well,
that the infant has a stronger attachment
to the father than the mother.
That's remarkable for a mammal.
They carry the infant,
they share food with the
infant more than the mother.
They groom, they touch, they play.
They're the primary caregivers, of course,
living outside nursing,
which is not trivial.
We wanted to understand
what are some possible
approximate causes of the
involvement of the father
with the care of the young,
how that may be feeding
and to explain pair bonding and monogamy.
And again, on purpose, I
just pasted the whole text
of this article because it
illustrates a little bit
what I'm trying to get traction
on in my own discipline.
Notice the paper is from 2021.
And for three years, a
holiness of grant went on
to collecting monkey shit
from the ground hoping that,
but this is the path
we're trying to connect.
So what is the hypothesis?
The hypothesis that for a
male to engage with a female,
one possibility is that the
male is helping the female
reduce the energetic burden.
If I help you take care of a young,
then you can rest, then you can sleep.
So we wanna look at endocrinology,
we wanna understand if
cortisol, which forget about,
don't think about cortisol
anymore as a stress hormone,
that's old, that's throw it
away, it's much more than that,
and we're thinking of it
as a metabolic gatekeeper.
Levels of cortisol are related
to how we're metabolizing glucose, right?
But that matters in the brain.
I mean, we need to, if I
could get the data I wanted,
I would like to know what's
happening with cortisol
and cortisol receptors in the brain.
I cannot do that.
Well, can you do blood?
No, I can't do that.
Can you do urine?
What can you do?
Well, I can collect monkey
poop from the ground
and hope that as a monkey excreted,
whatever it excreted,
something in the poop
gives me an adequate proxy
of cortisol in the brain.
We did that.
This is an unusual note
and section for our
journal and our discipline,
but we just wanted to do it.
And more and more, we're
doing multimodal selection,
model averaging.
But we can play with numbers all you want,
what we cannot allow ourselves to forget
is what is the quality,
the internal validity,
the elasticity of the
variables that we have.
And more and more, with my colleague
and my wife, Claudia
Valeggia, we're feeling like,
is it worth to put all this effort
in trying to infer something
about the energetics
of parental care from a measure
like the one we can get?
Ultimate causation, what are
the benefits of paternal care?
Huge survival of infants.
We think that may be
part of the explanation
of where we're seeing this.
You do not get these rates of
survival in any other primate.
For a wild animal, they
are doing wonderfully.
And maybe it's associated with having
both parents provide care.
The other ultimate question
is, okay, if this is adaptive,
if we can imagine this is
gonna evolve over time,
the same way I was talking about
why don't we see a polygenist
male strategy evolve?
How come did we get to have a
male care strategy to evolve?
For that, we need to understand
if there's father uncertainty
and if the males who are
keeping an eye on the females
are really the ones who
are siring the young.
It's crucial that we go from
describing their pattern
as sexual monogamy, social monogamy,
they're hanging together, sexual monogamy,
they are copulating with
each other, genetic monogamy,
they're really only producing
young with each other.
And we know now that the system
we have, it's quite extreme
because we have no other primate
for which we have the kind of data we do.
We have now tested 120 diets
of putative fathers and offspring,
and not a single time, we
have assigned the paternity
to another male that it is
not the putative father.
Most of you're familiar with the fact
that when we assess paternity,
we're not confirming the
identity of the father,
we're simply just deciding
which ones are not assigned paternity.
So that may be another answer,
partial answer to the evolution of this,
that a male who is committing
to a monogamous relationship
now succeeds in siring offspring
that in turn probably have
that tendency to provide care
as well and stay
pair-living and pair-bonded.
So the idea is that maybe
you really have pair bonding
as a necessary, but we don't
know if sufficient condition
to then facilitate the
evolution of fatherhood
and paternal care.
You can read about all this.
I added this because the
talk is gonna be public.
So you can see the Yale Today
for the whole piece on this.
And a book that we just
edited only this year,
it's bringing together
30 years of research
on owl monkeys all over Latin America.
And you can really find
there are some good synthesis
of the research that I have presented.
This is the last slide with a list.
I mean, really this is a
shopping list of the things
that I would like our discipline
to consider some more.
It is primarily observational.
We normally have very few subjects.
This is not for my discipline,
but I noticed yesterday,
we didn't really talk,
and I invite comments on this,
we didn't really get in our conversations
and presentations on what
differences are we gonna make
when we're talking about
prediction for the individual
and prediction for the population?
I think we have a lot to discuss there
because the public,
they're not getting it.
They're confusing our
talking about we can model,
we can predict, but we're not telling them
this is not gonna help you.
Sometimes, we have no clue about
what are important effect
sizes that we wanna find
or report or document.
We literally have no clue.
I don't know what is the
difference in cortisol
as estimated from poop
that really means something to the animal.
There's no discussion in my discipline
about the difference
between noise and bias.
Actually, I think indeed,
it's not happening in any field, right?
Now, everything's a bias.
Well, these are two different concepts.
I recommend that book that
Daniel Cunningham just published.
It's quite interesting to get the basics
of the distinction between those two.
Who was it yesterday?
Samantha made me think, oh,
my goodness, missing data.
Do we have work to do there?
So there are things we cannot do,
but all of these we can, let's do them.
If you're missing data, think about them.
Let me know why you didn't get those data.
I mean, what are the
causes of missing data?
That's huge.
We're not doing it enough I think.
For students, they confuse data
and inference from data all the time.
And then, all of this we
summarized in a commentary
to a journal of our main society
that we need to keep working.
This is central to the
workshop on the difference
between statistical inference
and causal inference.
Thanks to all the agencies.
And I thought that would be
a nice collage to finish.
(attendees clapping)
- [Priya] Thanks so much,
Eduardo, for opening eyes
to very long causal chains that are needed
in inference in your discipline.
So we're open for questions.
Yulia.
Yako.
- [Attendee 1] That was fascinating.
So I learned that Barbary macaques
are also excellent fathers,
but the reason there is like
these groups like live together
and because paternity's uncertain,
the males look after all the children
just in case they're theirs.
And actually males form
bonds in Barbary macaques
over like the looking after the young.
So I mean, the result is the same,
that they're very good fathers,
but actually the relationship
they have with the females
and the males have with each
other are very different.
So I was wondering, you know,
like even in different types
of creatures with maybe
similar type of habitat,
similar type of resources
and so on, like, you know,
like you get to the same outcome
for very different reasons.
And how can you untangle these things
and how does more broadly,
is it clear what determines
whether a group lives together
and there's like, like a
bigger group lives together
as a patriarchy or matriarchy or like,
there's like, just like pairs
basically, like in this case?
- So thanks.
I'm reminding myself that
this is gonna be recorded
and made public, but I'm
not gonna say anything
that I haven't already
published in writing.
So the Barbary macaques,
there's one single paper,
empirical paper from the seventies,
it was a relatively short
paper on Barbary macaques
that again, and again gets
drawn into the same pool
of all studies without distinguishing
how robust the information is.
My understanding is that Barbary macaques,
some colleagues of mine have
studied to work on them again.
But the outcomes are the same,
but the extent to which the
questions have been examined,
I don't think they are.
So going to the Barbary, but
what matters what you said
is I think it's
interesting that it is true
that it's difficult to measure.
We have tons of papers discussing
how we're gonna define
paternal care, right?
I mean, think about your own families.
What does it mean that a pair of yours
is taking care of you?
More and more we are learning
with studies across societies
or human societies that there could be
a lot of observational learning
that the young do from the father,
but if we're looking at the
father, I mean if we didn't know
that the son is there, we
would not be describing
this adult male as teaching anything,
but the child is learning from the father
just through observation.
So we make, in a very simplistic way,
we talk about direct
care and indirect care.
The Barbary macaque like every
single other primate I know,
except for the titi monkeys do
not have in any way or manner
the kind of direct
involvement with the young,
transporting them, caring.
I mean, the baby yells and
dad goes to its rescue.
Now, it is possible, absolutely possible,
but much harder to document
that the mere presence
of adult males are providing
some extent of care
because those males may be a
barrier to potential predators.
Those males may be a
barrier to potential males
who may kill those infants.
So how we assess,
then you brought up the word
bond, which I did as well.
And that's a rabbit hole
because again, how are
we going to define bond?
We do not have.
I use the word for our
research in the wild.
But if you ask me, I mean,
I will say here on record
that I don't know if
we have any solid data
to speak about a bond for
the owl monkeys in Argentina.
This is another way in which
in biological anthropology,
we can make our inferences more robust.
We can draw, we can use
the process of abduction.
We need to do comparative biology
because the way in which
I can do it is, okay,
I don't know if a male
and female owl monkey,
I don't know if the male
and the infant have a bond
in the sense that if I
cut that relationship,
there's gonna be distress.
I haven't shown that.
I haven't shown that
they will seek each other
because they're always together.
I cannot say parting them, right?
But I'm started looking around
and I see there are all kinds of studies
spanning decades on all
kinds of other systems
where when they see what I
see, they have also shown
that there's a substrate,
that there are proximate mechanisms,
there's a physiology,
there's an endocrinology
that speaks of a bond.
We don't have that for Barbary macaques,
technically speaking, we
don't have it for owl monkeys.
The closest we get is to some
research on callitrichids
and titi monkeys in captivity
where there is some wonderful
work documenting the bonds.
So how you get to that.
Barbary macaques live in groups
where you have several
males and several females,
and again, we do not have
evidence that the relationship
between males and females
in those groups is similar
to the relationship you
have in pair-living taxa.
But how we really make
progress in understanding
how we got there, it's
profoundly difficult.
I do have hopes in terms of the genetics,
but the genetics then also,
seeing how the genetics unfold, right?
We need to make so much more progress
in the black box between genes or genomes
and these very, very complex phenotype.
- [Priya] Yep.
- [Attendee 2] Thank you.
It's a wonderful topic.
And I was wondering if you could
say a little bit more about
the statistical norm that was
just mentioned in the paper
that you wrote and whether
there have been discussions
and people have been
questioning the statistic.
- Statistical, I'm sorry,
- Norm.
So in the paper, in the,
one more back is the, sorry,
the one, there's a footnote
in your third to last slide.
- P value.
- Yeah, the P value.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
- This one.
- Yes.
- Can you say a little
bit more about that?
- Yes, absolutely, don't get me started.
- Oh, well maybe you
shouldn't say something.
- I'd love to, I have to.
- Briefly comment.
- I have two minutes.
Already in the nineties, I
was trained by psychologists,
they knew about meta-analysis,
there wasn't anything new about it, right?
They knew about meta-analysis.
But already, back when I was
a grad student, I realized
that now hypothesis significance testing
was profoundly inadequate
for everything I was doing.
And still, I still have
tables full of stars.
It looks like a cosmology experiment.
So now, in 2021, again,
through this period, we decided
that we wanted to share
with our colleagues,
but this was because I was
following with my colleagues
at the American Statistical Association
and the statement that the
American Statistical Association
published in 2016 saying
misuse and use of p-values,
they needed to include
the use in the title.
But the bottom line is 99% of
people are misusing p-values
and statistical significance
followed by the nature paper
with a hundred signatories
saying, let's stop doing this.
And I'm begging, you stop doing it
because I think it's made so much damage
for most research situations.
Definitely I'm speaking for ours.
In biological anthropology,
there are seldom any opportunities
where you're gonna make progress,
definitely not in causal inference
by deciding whether this
is worth reporting or not,
based on an arbitrate dichotomous cutoff,
that it's the same no
matter what you're studying.
So again, I'll go on record.
What was the reaction?
That it was the first time in my life
that the two reviewers said
this has to be published
and the editor decided
to send it to a third
and the third said, this
has to be published.
And the editor eventually,
I guess she published it.
But why don't we see traction?
I think it's because we need
to train our younger colleagues
to take responsibility.
You are the expert.
We need to go back to domain knowledge.
I think it was Samantha
again, the easiest is,
no, I don't know what this means,
but the piece 0.04, it
ought to be important.
That's what we're getting
from students a lot.
And they're not thinking.
I go back to my second slide.
You have to know your discipline.
You have to think hard,
you have to think deep,
you have to be open and modest
with what you hope you can
accomplish and all that,
it's absolutely counter to
structuring your findings
and publications around an arbitrary.
For me, it's mind blowing
that we're still using 0.05
and we haven't.
So there was a lot.
But I'm optimistic, I'm
optimistic we're making progress.
- Two quick questions.
- [Attendee 3] Oh, one
quick question, yeah.
Okay, sorry.
So I just, I have one.
So one, the question is,
what inferences do you have
about how your monkeys choose their mates?
Or to put it differently,
what's the nature of love?
- The nature of love, the nature of love-
- [Priya] Very quick answer.
- Right, the nature of love, I suggest,
let's talk about it
later, but the inference,
how they choose, that's
where you need a lab.
That's where you can really have,
we have a lot of expertise in
how we can assess preference,
be of mates, be of food,
anything you choose.
So we can do that in the lab.
We haven't yet, because the
challenge is, even if we do it
with a very carefully
crafted study design,
we still have relatively
low number of subjects.
And so, and I suspect that the answers
are gonna be all over the place.
It'll have to be done in the lab
and that's as much as I can
say with the time we have.
I'd love to, let's sit down,
we can all contribute the
same about the nature of love.
I mean, I'm no expert there.
Thank you.
(attendees clapping)